l'urgence pour parler à nouveau de ce
qui m'a dit Madame Macron disait à
l'instant l'urgence est de trouver une
solution pour la compétitivité de
l'économie et de l'industrie européenne
surtout la guerre en Ukraine a privé
l'Union européenne de son modèle
énergétique c'est-à-dire que 80 % du gaz
russe et désormais coupé et ce gaz russe
était essentiel pour une grande partie
de l'industrie européenne en particulier
en Allemagne donc un vrai problème de
compétitivité et l'autre gros problème
de compétitivité c'est l'arrêt le la loi
américaine de réduction de l'inflation
plus de 400 milliards de dollars mis sur
la table par les États-Unis ce qui est
un vrai problème de concurrence déloyale
disent presque les Européens et ils
veulent pousser aujourd'hui pour par
exemple assouplir les aides d'État en
faveur des technologies propres des
technologies vertes des énergies
renouvelables de manière à mettre sur la
table une loi à l'européenne un aéré à
l'Européen pour la réduction de
l'inflation de manière à rester
compétitive parce parce que sinon
l'industrie européenne va perdre tous
ses moyens d'investissement qui
pourraient fuir de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique ou ailleurs dans le monde